as Easter arrives once again many people
around the world naturally start
thinking about Jesus and the earliest
history of Christianity it is after all
that these two Christians a holiday of
commemoration for the death and
resurrection of Christ and the early
history and formation of Christianity is
such a fascinating and interesting topic
as we've talked about in my many
previous episodes on this topic it is a
complex world of different schools and
interpretations lost ancient texts and
Intrigue and as we once again turn to
the world of non-canonical scriptures
that is texts that were not included in
the Bible for various reasons we get to
one of the most striking and interesting
of the so-called Gnostic Gospels the
Gospel of Mary
a text that gives a very different
interpretation of some of the core
theological teachings of Christianity
from the mainstream version that we're
used to and which may also hints or
represent some of the schisms and
debates that were being had in the
earliest history of the largest religion
in the world
foreign
[Applause]
the Gospel of Mary is a relatively short
book at least in the form that it
survives it's a text to offer some
really interesting theological positions
contrary to those of mainstream
Christianity as well as tackling topics
of gender and the leadership of women
through placing the figure of Mary at
its Center as a primary disciple and
maybe even heir to Jesus
unlike many of the other famous
non-canonical scriptures such as the
Gospel of Thomas the Gospel of Mary was
not found among the text of the nag
hamadu Library discovered in 1945.
indeed it was first uncovered in the
19th century
this is a text that seems to have been
rather popular among certain communities
of Christians for a few centuries in
Antiquity but which then completely
disappeared from history with the
gradual rise and dominance of Orthodoxy
it wasn't until 1896 that it was
rediscovered in Egypt along with a few
other texts written in Coptic and dating
from the 5th Century this is still the
most complete version of the text that
we have but that isn't really saying
much indeed the first six pages of the
Codex are missing as well as four full
pages right in the middle with that in
mind we actually only have about half of
this text but that's still enough to
glean some of its amazing contents and
unique teachings in the early 20th
century two other fragments of the text
were found both of them written in Greek
these fragments sadly don't include any
of the Lost parts of the Coptic version
but they are significant for another
reason they are much earlier
the Greek manuscripts of the Gospel of
Mary both date from the early 3rd
century and so we can be absolutely
certain that it wasn't written any later
than that time with that said Scholars
don't exactly agree on the true dating
of the text although I would say that
the current majority consensus is that
it probably dates from the early 2nd
Century this makes it a significantly
early text in the history of
Christianity not as early as the
canonical gospels or the letters of Paul
for example but still very early and
this gives us an idea of the context in
which this text was composed as we have
explored in various earlier videos the
early centuries of Christianity were
incredibly diverse and complex there
wasn't as often assumed an orthodox
church that had to fight off a bunch of
heresies instead the early Jesus
movement consisted of various different
communities or quote-unquote churches
spread out across the Mediterranean and
Middle Eastern worlds these community
these could have vastly different ideas
about even the most fundamental aspects
of Christian doctrine was Jesus divine
or a human Messiah what is his
relationship with God or his followers
to uphold Jewish law or abandon it what
is the nature of Salvation all of these
questions were up for debate basically
remember this is before any Nicene Creed
or church councils that would eventually
establish an Orthodoxy this was a world
of christianities not Christianity and
various doctrinal and practical
Tendencies existed simultaneously all
with an equal claim to represent the
quote-unquote true teachings of Jesus
one such community that eventually
crystallized was the so-called gnostics
that we have dedicated a full episode to
with their incredibly complicated
cosmology of various eons and an
ignorant demiurge as the creator of the
physical world we also have the
community associated with the Gospel of
Thomas we're often referred to as
thomasine Christians that emphasis sized
self-knowledge as the means to Salvation
and an emphasis on an imminentist almost
monist adjacent theology
and there were of course also those
thinkers that were more aligned with
what would eventually become Orthodoxy
such as the famous heresiologist
irenaeus
in this complex and diverse environment
the Gospel of Mary is composed by one of
these communities
the identification of the authors is one
that has been speculated on but it is
ultimately impossible to know with that
said and as will become clear when we
explore the contents the author and
audience seems to be strongly familiar
or comfortable with Greek philosophy
rather than with Judaism as such
suggesting perhaps a gentile Community
some Scholars have suggested that it was
indeed composed in a hellenized Egypt in
particular
the Gospel of Mary is often called a
Gnostic Gospel as are basically all the
non-canonical scriptures sometimes and
if you've been watching this channel
then you know that I have something of a
beef with this broad use of the term the
gnostics if that term can be used at all
seems to be a particular community of
other Christians associated with a
particular kind of Theology and many of
the texts are often labeled Gnostic such
as the Gospel of Thomas for instance
don't really fit into that category and
was more likely written by an
independent community of its own so
what's the case with the Gospel of Mary
then well basically the same I would say
I would be careful to call this agnostic
gospel because there isn't really much
about it that's Gnostic in any way there
is no mention of an ignorant demiurge
that creates the world there is no
mention of the barbello as a Divine
principle not even any indication of the
very clear and distinct dualism of the
gnostics even though there is a can of
dualism in this text too but so many of
these features that are so particular to
the gnostics aren't really present in
this text so what's going on with this
text what makes it so unique and why
wasn't it included in the canonical
Bible
well again similar to The Gospel of
Thomas it kind of isn't really a gospel
in the traditional sense
it doesn't include any biographical
stories about Jesus's life or Ministry
instead it's essentially retelling a
conversation between Jesus and his
disciples and then turns to one where
Mary is teaching the other followers
about some secret teachings of Jesus
indeed Mary plays the central role in
this text which is why it's called the
Gospel of Mary now it's basically
completely certain that it wasn't
written by Mary herself but the work
very much revolves around her but which
Mary is this there are after all a few
Mary's in the life of Jesus while there
have been some speculation among
Scholars most would argue that this is
indeed Mary of magdala or Mary Magdalene
who was after all one of the close
Disciples of Jesus what's so fascinating
about this text is the prominent role
that she is given among the group indeed
certain sections seems to indicate that
she is the foremost disciple out of all
of them and even indicates that Jesus
liked her more than the others thus
making her a kind of Heir or chief
successor in a kind of way this mirrors
some of the famous sections in the
Gospel of Philip where it is also told
that Mary had a special status among the
disciples and that controversially Jesus
even used to quote kiss her on the mouth
which has naturally led to all kind of
speculations about their relationship in
any case when we read the text we find
out that it starts right in the middle
of a sentence as we said the first six
pages of the text are missing and so we
had to sort of guess what's going on
here it seems to be a scene where Jesus
has already resurrected and is giving
his disciples a kind of last teaching
before finally leaving for heaven so
this is a so-called post-resurrection
narrative and from here in the part of
the text that we actually have there are
some truly fascinating quotes and
teachings that he conveys Jesus who is
referred to in the text simply as the
Savior first talks about the fate of
matter and describes how all matter will
eventually dissolve into its original
form quote they will dissolve again into
their own proper roots for the nature of
matter is dissolved into what belongs to
its nature
already we see indications here that the
contents are influenced by Greek
philosophical thinking and later in the
text we'll see more possible traces of
things like platonism and stoicism
but what's important here is the fact
that matter is temporary including the
body
matter will eventually dissolve and will
not endure rather it's the soul that is
Immortal our true self there is no talk
of any bodily Resurrection at the end of
time or punishment in hell in this text
quite a contrary it seems to deny any
such resurrection and the reality of
Hell at least in a physical sense
instead the Savior urges us to forget
about the material and focus on the soul
and the spiritual it is that which
survives the death of the body and thus
that that should be focused on it's
after this that the text offers its
perhaps the most shocking idea when
asked about Sin the Savior called the
replies quote there is no such thing as
Sin rather you yourselves are what
produces sin when you act in accordance
with the nature of adultery which is
called sin what does Jesus mean here
well it's basically a continuation of
the previous discussion on matter since
the true human self is only identified
as the non-material soul good and evil
and hence sin cannot exist on the
material physical level The Scholar
Karen King says quote
from this perspective sin does not
really exist insofar as it is conceived
as action in the material world which
will be dissolved
at death the soul is released from the
body and ascends to rest with God Beyond
Time and Eternity
the corpse returns to the inanimate
material substance or nothingness out of
which it arose as a result ethical
concern is focused upon strengthening
the spiritual self since it is the true
Immortal real self
true sin is an estrangement from God of
not realizing one's true self as the
soul that can Ascend to God and in which
the Divine world is imminent
this focus on the bodily and material is
described by the Savior as a kind of
adultery a betrayal of our true nature
with the false self of the body
this dualism is already somewhat
platonist in nature but becomes even
more so as the Savior says quotes become
content at heart while also remaining
discontent indeed become contented only
in the presence of every true image of
nature
in other words seek only the Divine
world to which the soul has access which
here seems very similar to the platonic
world of forms not the material world
this is really the core of the teachings
of the Gospel of Mary
it is through the teachings of the
Savior that we reach salvation
a teaching that we are to turn inward to
our true selves to find the Divine realm
there and this is perhaps best expressed
in the following section where the
Savior really kind of seals the deal
here the son of man or the child of
humanity represents that Divine image
within that Divine realm that the soul
can Ascend to
quote be on your guard so that no one
deceives you by saying look over here or
look over there for the child of
humanity exists within you follow it
those who search for it will find it
after this Mike dropped Jesus then tells
his disciples basically to go out and
preach the gospels right spread the good
news and the teachings that he has
conveyed to them and then he basically
just leaves right permanently this time
he leaves for heaven and as a result of
this the disciples aren't exactly
pleased in fact they're completely
distraught they all start weeping in
despair they're all scared essentially
because they believe or think that if
they are going to go out and spread the
message that Jesus taught then they will
also suffer the same fate as he did that
is execution basically
so all the disciples are crying and in
despair completely
all except one
Mary
indeed this is where Mary enters the
picture as the main character of the
story
significantly she here takes on the role
of a teacher even of the other disciples
she is the only one that isn't sad about
the savior's departure because she is
the only one that truly understood his
message if our true self is the
immaterial soul
the death of the body is nothing to fear
this High status and role of Mary is
really interesting given the later
attitudes in Christianity towards women
teachers in the church here it is Mary
who comforts the other disciples she's
asked by Peter quote sister we know that
the savior loves you more than all other
women tell us the words of the saber
that you remember the things you know
that we don't because we haven't heard
them after which she starts teaching
telling them about what the saber taught
only her in secret
she tells them about a vision she had of
him as well as basically going through
an entire Narrative of the ascent of the
Soul
sadly it's precisely here that we are
missing another four pages of the text
right in the middle of the most juicy
stuff but once the text resumes it
becomes clear that she's describing how
the immaterial soul can gradually escape
this body and material world through an
encounter with seven so-called powers
that try to drag the soul down and keep
it in this fleshly world these seven
powers are Darkness desire ignorance
Zeal for death the realm of the flesh
the wisdom of the Flesh and the wisdom
of the wrathful person
as the soul ascends on its journey to
God it has to fight off all these Powers
transcend them until it finally escapes
and can rest in the Silence of its true
nature a state of true peace as it has
reached the Divine quote from this hour
on for the time of the Jewish season of
the age I will receive rest in silence
Mary says this as she herself Falls
silence almost embodying the Soul at
peace what the Savior earlier referred
to when he said quote become content at
heart and acquire peace within
yourselves
this is the main thrust of the whole
gospel to attain this piece means to
turn within to our true self and help
that self ascend from the material to
its Eternal rest in the Peace of the
Divine embrace
but as Mary has finished telling the
other disciples about this she's
basically attacked by them Andrew first
basically questions the entire thing by
saying that these are strange teachings
that they have never heard from the
Savior themselves and then Peter jumps
in and also criticizes and questions
Mary for the fact that the Savior
supposedly taught secret teachings in
private and even more so to a woman here
we get to the very interesting
discussions of gender in the text
Mary is very distraught over these
comments and starts to weep while trying
to defend herself
and it is another disciple Levy that
takes her side and starts criticizing
Peter for being so hot tempered quote
now I see you contending against the
woman like the adversaries for if the
Sabers made her worthy who are you then
for your part to reject her assuredly
the savior's knowledge of her is
completely reliable that is why he loved
her more than us
this is a significant quote especially
that last part where Levy says that
Jesus apparently loved Mary more than
the other disciples
this again Echoes the ideas expressed in
the Gospel of Philip where Mary is given
a very special role as the favorite
disciple of Jesus and then after this
the text basically ends with the
disciples deciding to go out and spread
the gospels just like the Savior had
asked them to before but core of this
text especially in the interdiscipal
tension at the end lies some really
interesting themes that might reflect
schisms in the early church
the discussion about women as Leaders or
teachers seems to have been one of the
many discussions that were had at the
time alongside other discussions
regarding christology and salvation for
example
the authors of the Gospel of Mary
certainly seems to have been a community
that had no problem with women as
Leaders as they Place Mary Magdalene in
such a prominent position
this is in opposition to those
sentiments expressed in for example the
letters of Paul and in other pieces of
scripture that ended up in the Bible
that seems to rather highly criticize
the idea of women as teachers of men
what's so interesting is that it is
Peter who takes the critical side here
against Mary Peter is after all the
disciple who is The Rock on which the
church is built thus representing what
would become the Orthodoxy in other
words are we seeing in this text a
reflection of real debates that were had
in the early Christian communities and
maybe even among some of the disciples
themselves
my friend Dr Justin Sledge on the
channel esoterica discusses this
question more in depth in his much
longer video on the Gospel of Mary which
you should definitely check out if
you're interested but that's basically
it this is a text that not only gives us
a fascinating look into some early
discussions about gender and Leadership
but also contain some truly remarkable
theological teachings the text never
neglects the crucifixion of Jesus indeed
unlike the Gospel of Thomas it seems to
refer to this event directly when the
disciples are afraid of suffering the
same fate as the Savior at the same time
though it's not this death of Jesus on
the cross that is at the core of
Salvation like for Orthodox Christianity
instead it is the teachings of the
Savior and following those teachings
that can help the soul to Salvation
a teaching where our true self is not
the material body with the immaterial
soul which can transcend the physical by
ascending through the different powers
until it reaches the uterus silence and
peace of its true nature with the divine
this is thus a text that has features in
common with various philosophical
traditions there isn't much that is
quote unquote Jewish about the teachings
here at all instead we can see more
clear traces of platonism stoicism and
perhaps even hermeticism which suggests
to Scholars that the author and audience
of this text might have been Hellenic
Gentile Christians perhaps living in
Egypt as we said earlier it's truly an
amazing little text and in my opinion
one of the most interesting of the
non-canonical scriptures while it wasn't
included in the canonical Bible it seems
to have been pretty popular for the
first few centuries over the
Christianity right up until the 5th
Century which is where we have the the
the latest manuscripts dated right the
the last manuscripts that we know of are
from the 5th Century and so it seems
that around that time which is at around
the same time that you know the
so-called Orthodoxy had started to
really develop and and become
sets in a way at around that time the
Gospel of Mary seems to go out of
fashion so to say but before this you
know just the fact that we have three
different manuscripts three examples of
this text and in two different languages
that's more than most of these old texts
that suggest that this was actually a
pretty popular text for the first few
centuries but even today it can help us
contemplate the context and environment
in which the largest religion in the
world was gradually formed over the
first centuries of the Common Era I
would like to thank my patrons for
supporting this channel it really is
thanks to you that I'm able to do this
work and so I am I'll never get tired of
saying how humbled and grateful I am for
all of your support
patreon is really the best way to
support this channel in terms of the
view count and all that stuff it can
vary so much from month to month and so
it's hard to to to plan ahead and to
budget Things based on that and so
patreon really is the best way to
support this Channel and I would highly
appreciate if anyone else wanted to
become a member a patron so I will leave
links to all that stuff in the
description
thank you all so much for watching and I
will see you next time
[Music]
foreign